Collette there is no collapse
you can make this work just shoot us an
opening bit
all right
[Music]
I figured this moment would come you
figured this moment would come you
brought me here I did what I was
supposed to do Kyrie no don't leave me
with these scrubs
luckily you're able to join this super
team right so it's just like y'all's
downtown or no this is the Nash pass the
quickest way to the tournament and where
I can finally beat him
that's them all right Luke is carrying
all the weight attack
risk thank you
wait
it's Kyrie and he's actually planning on
participating
[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin you must relax relax there's no
relaxed chance
okay what's the game plan look I'm not
the Savior here I'm watching just like
everyone else
good thing it's just my sons hello food
it's Daddy Luca
totally legitimate Warriors rig go
oh
[Music]
Dollar's shooting more than me DeAndre
oh fear I don't want to be here
looks like the odds are even
your numbers
oh illegal Powerball he took three stabs
doesn't count
well I've done my role
[Music]
come on Russ I mean Steph I mean
isolation chamber
started it we started it how am I
growing
I can't believe I said you you'll have
to be more Civic you said you did what
you were supposed to do did that include
betraying your best friend
you don't have to answer your silence
speaks volumes Easy Money mid-range
invisible Defender
[Music]
[Applause]
Kyrie no don't leave me with these
scrollers
[Music]
don't you see I saved you I saved you
because
I may want to join the Suns next year no
Kyrie not again I mean well maybe if you
but no come on for some reason the mass
have been terrible since I got here I
mean yeah but
while they focus on their lethal rivalry
the number one seed can go straight to
play off Mountain
foreign
[Music]
I think
you might be the better player
really
though
I feel good to laugh
[Music]